- [speaking spanish]
[speaking spanish]
Two of my senior guys violated
an SOP written in blood.
We were committed, bro.
No, you ran off after a
squirter with a suicide vest.
No.
That squirter was our HVI.
What were we supposed to
do, just let the guy go?
- Alex?
- You all right?
You still getting
those headaches?
My asset from Bosnia, John,
you know him as the Prince.
They knew we were coming.
God, did you screw us?
John betrayed me.
We think the Russians helped
him become the prince.
We need to spend
some time apart.
Things have to change.
We have to change.
It's lonely at the top, Joe.
No God to believe in, a country
that doesn't believe in you.
I want you to go away now.
You know that avatar,
Golden Boy, the Prince?
He ordered your death, Michael.
He told Muttaqi to
give you to Boko Haram.
Where is he?
My end of the deal.